mais un nouveau look d'arrivée bienvenue à la plage
et à la maison votre chambre est une belle suite
dans ce que nous appelons les ailes d'abeilles sonne
comme une prison va changer là aussi les garçons
je sais qui c'est aussi grand que la vie et
deux fois plus terrifiant je vais  dire
quelque chose de très grossier
toi
toi et toi
pauvre elle a tellement de mal
est une maison folle
nous avons un sérieux problème nous ne pouvons pas faire
l'ail pour le billet le plus chaud de la
ville cette maison pourrait s'effondrer nous pourrions la
perdre nous avons quatre de  les meilleurs
chanteurs de l'histoire de l'opéra anglais je
ne pense pas que je veuille chanter à nouveau avec gène
ils se sont mariés une fois mais ça
n'a pas marché nous étions des gens différents
alors
j'ai une idée brillante
oh je ne me souviens plus de
quoi  t'a fait arrêter de chanter tu dois
comprendre j'étais quelqu'un une fois
pourquoi as-tu persisté à flirter avec moi
homme plus âgé vin vintage bois assaisonné
c'est la première fois que nous nous
voyons si dieu sait combien d'années 97. oh
est-ce vraiment ça  longtemps
tout le monde pense que l'opéra et le rap un  re
deux choses complètement différentes ça
parle juste pour nous et regarde juste la
façon dont ils
leur amour de la vie
est contagieux ils nous inspirent
il n'est pas trop tard il me dit d'aller de l'avant
et de sentir les roses et il chante
je pense que je le suis peut-être même si je trouve  il est
très difficile de faire la différence à
cet âge